[Musique]
le sénateur cher jean pierre grand votre
question est importante j'ai eu
l'occasion de répondre
il y a quelques semaines à l'assemblée
nationale à une question similaire et
est chaud c'est le travail qui étaient
fournies par les sénateurs qui est
important et notamment je crois par
votre collègue valérie létard qui a été
qui a écrit et défendu une proposition
parlementaire de loi qui a été adoptée
ici même à l'unanimité je crois qu'elles
aient perdu la navette parlementaire
qu'elle doit en ressortir prochainement
pour arriver à l'assemblée nationale où
je vous le dis sans ambages j'aurai à
coeur d'accompagner ce texte voire de le
renforcer et d'améliorer partout où ce
sera nécessaire parce que votre question
soulève un vrai problème de santé
publique
et vous le savez toutes et tous ici
puisque vous êtes un certain nombre à
être interpellé par les maires qui font
face au dépôt sauvage de cartouches de
ce gaz qui n'a d'hilarants que le nom et
beaucoup de gens se posent la question
savoir comment faire comme pour toute
addiction
il ya d'abord les campagnes qui sont
menées par la mission de lutte contre
les addictions d'amyle des cas il ya
également des accompagnements qui
peuvent être faits en addictologie les
cas de suivi par addictologie ces
quelques dizaines en revanche ce gaz qui
il est vrai à une consommation
extrêmement brève procure une faurie
parfois des hallucinations et régresse
sans laisser de séquelles présente une
dangerosité en réalité qui est ignorée
par les jeunes qui sont trop nombreux à
le consommer notamment la première des
dangerosité je crois que si on arrive
déjà expliqué ce risque aux jeunes ils
seront moins nombreux à considérer que
c'est pas grave de le consommer c'est un
gaz qui est stocké dans des capsules
extrêmement réfrigérée et les cas
d'accidents les plus graves sont des cas
de brûlures mortels l'ensemble des voies
respiratoires et des bronches et quand
je dis mortels c'est parce que ça
provoque la mort parce que la
consommation de ces capsules lorsqu'elle
n'est pas maîtrisé et on ne peut pas le
prédire au moment de sortir une capsule
par exemple de deux machines
distributrices de chantilly peut
provoquer le décès et c'est de ce sont
des drames terribles on parle de jeunes
de 18 19 20 ans et qui se retrouve alors
qu'ils ne s'y attendaient pas les
proches ne s'y attendait évidemment
parce qu'ils m'ont ils dit ignor la
dangerosité et puis il ya des séquelles
neurologiques peuvent apparaître la
scène neurologue qui vous le dit avec
des séquelles qui peuvent être
irréversibles donc sous couvert d'une
consommation d'un produit qu'on peut
acheter par paquets de 100 sur internet
qui coûte pas bien cher et qui fait
marrer les copains
en réalité on met gravement sa vie en
jeu l'action des maires peut être
déterminante via des interdits
on localise et de consommation notamment
sur la voie publique
également dans le repérage des capsules
qui doit donner lieu à un renforcement
des campagnes de prévention en lien avec
la rs en attendant donc cette belle doit
que vous avez commencé
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs à
travailler et que j'espère qui j'espère
verra sa concrétisation d'ici à la fin
du mandat